this morning the brother of a Michigan
man detained in Russia is rejecting
Moscow's claim he is a spy 48 year old
Paul Whelan a former US Marine was
arrested on Friday and he was charged
with espionage Jan Crawford is outside
Russia's Embassy in Washington with
reaction to the detention of Whelan Jan
good morning
well good morning so Paul Wieland's twin
brother David told us that his brother
had gone to Russia on December 22nd for
a friend's wedding and the last time he
heard from him was last Friday it was
only on Monday and through media reports
that the family became aware that the 48
year old had been detained now in a
statement Russia's Federal Security
Services says that officers arrested
Whelan in Moscow on Friday while he was
on what they said was a spy mission but
all this is prompting speculation that
it's just kind of retaliation some kind
of payback for the u.s. arresting a
Russian woman Maria Bettina on spy
charges now Whelan since 2017 has worked
for a michigan-based auto parts company
called BorgWarner most recently was
director of their global security and he
spent 14 years in the Marines according
to the military he was discharged back
in 2008 for bad conda related to larceny
his brother told CBS News that Paul
Whelan had been to Russia several times
before and knew how to avoid trouble he
said it was inconceivable he could be
considered a spy he has a law
enforcement background he was a former
US Marine who served a number of tours
in Iraq he does corporate security it's
the sort of personality that you
wouldn't expect to be a lawbreaker of
any sort let alone someone who's you
know breaking spy laws former Secretary
of State Mike Pompeo
I just told reporters moments ago that
the State Department had requested
access immediate access to Whelan and
Secretary of State Pompeo said that they
also expected his immediate release if
this detention proved inappropriate
all right Jan thank you so much